i bought this
i bought this in an airport oh wow uh
they had one that said playwright which
i have here they had another one that
said arthur and i bought that one i
don't know where it is and there was
another one that said dog catcher and if
i could find it i'd wear it
but i can't find that one either so play
writer yeah play right yeah i think
playwright's way better than a dog
well i don't know you know
we we actually uh had a very stressful
day yesterday because
in the middle of the night someone
deposited a dog in our front yard
and we have a little wall about that
high that the puppy wasn't a little
puppy it was you know but a puppy
it'll be a bigger dog
um they just dumped
and at six o'clock in the morning my
wife went to get the paper and she said
i need your help we got this puppy he's
been
moaning and groaning and he's scared and
the whole thing
and so we took it in and we fed it and
we were debating do we keep it because
we have a german shepherd and the two of
them weren't the german shepherd didn't
wasn't crazy about it
the german shepherd's name is penelope
and so we named the dog homer
um
and by the end of the day we were
exhausted we realized the the dog's not
house broken we don't have time to walk
it along with the other dog it was not
so
we finally decided we're going to have
to find someone who will adopt the dog
but
we love the dog so much within that one
day we both bonded that
where are we going to find someone who's
going to take good care of it that's
tough yep and
she went to the pet store where we bring
our dog and
the trainer there
he saw a picture we took a picture of
the dog he looked at me went
that's an australian cattle dog they're
very expensive and my wife said would
you like it would you like to take it
because we can't handle it
he said i've been looking for an
australian cattle dog that you know
i've been looking for it he was so
thrilled and he's a trainer and he and
his wife came over last night and
they bonded and the dog is okay but
at the end of the day i said to my i'm
wiped out
yeah we've had that's how we had a cat
for like 16 17 years just showed up at
the door stressed crying right and
probably someone dumped it and um i know
yeah our first cat was like that yeah
she was under a house scared to death
you know and that cat cleo
when
she she died um
she had been attacked by a dog and we
brought her to the vet
and her wounds were pretty bad and the
vet said i'm afraid she's probably not
going to live very long
and he said you want to leave her here
with us and i said no no we're going to
take her home and she will
um
if she passes away it'll be here in our
house so we took her home and he said
but you know if she is going to survive
you have to give
this eye dropper in her mouth every hour
so i laid on the floor next to her
and every hour i didn't sleep that night
every hour i gave her a little bit of
this medicine
and at some point and then i would fall
asleep and then i'd wake up and give her
some more and at one point about four in
the morning i think it was
when i went to feel her
i could feel the body had
rigor mortis had said
it's that stiffness
she's dead
and i just stayed with her and then
about 6 30
my wife walked in and she said how's
cleo
and
i said she died
and i started crying
i've never i don't think i've cried that
hard since i broke up with
somebody when i was a senior in high
school
i started crying
so heavy
and then i realized what it was
i was crying for my father
because i never grieved for my father
because it's a long story but
i kind of skipped over the grief part
and i reel and this is like 30 years
later here i am crying and i went i'm
crying for my father
and just
man it just came out
and uh and you know we
put her in a box and we
we buried her and so forth or had her
buried that kind of thing
but boy animals they can really rip your
heart out yeah they can and i've rescued
a lot of cats or we have and yeah um you
know they they appreciate it i don't
think i've ever i've only purchased them
from rescues i've never purchased a
purebred or anything yeah yeah we've
always rescued our pets chucky who we
had to put up had cancer we had to put
her down
she used to come up on my he used to
come up on my desk when i was working
and she would plop right down on my
checkbook
and rather than move her i would
you know try to write the checks and put
them in the envelopes without disturbing
uh him oh yeah we know all about it yeah
that's our daily right right animals man
they're yeah they're wonderful though
okay anyway you have yeah let me um okay
um
you have a concept you teach called
image moment
oh it's very complicated okay and
it's
a cinematic it's a cinematic
construct in writing that most people
don't do
because it's not intuitive
something you have to learn to do
but it takes a moment in a dramatic
scene and how to
create psychological time
um
so that the reader is in that dramatic
moment as if it was a movie like when
you're in a movie and someone says
something and then there's a pause and
then say something else and it's like
wow one of those great moments you know
oh rhett what will i do where will i go
pause
frankly my dear i don't give a damn
you know so when you're writing it
you're not making the movie you're
writing it
how do you create that pause
and that moment of drama
um
so that the reader feels they're
watching the movie and that they're in
the movie you know they're watching it
you and you create psychological time
the psychological time is the pause the
pause might only last a second in the
movie but psychologically it could last
forever
so the husband comes home and she says
i listen to your messages today you went
oh
she said are you having an affair
pause
uh no
so the drama
in that pause
how do you make that psychological that
real time which is only two seconds
psychological so that it feels forever
well there's a way to i have a lot of
techniques that you do and what you do
it's a long it's a long mechanical
construct but uh
image moment because you're creating a
moment using images
and creating psychological time
it takes people a while to learn how to
master it because most people want to
just tell their story and stopping and
doing an image moment
feels like they're not going with the
flow of their story so you have to train
people to do that
do you think that's what's missing in a
lot of let's say first time screenplays
or films is that psychological time that
pacing it's too fast a screenplay can't
create psychological time the filmmaker
can create it
all you can create in a screenplay is
dialogue
you can't tell the actors to pause you
can write it in the screenplay but it
doesn't mean they're going to listen to
you
you can say cinematic pause here well
the director may go
no we're going to do it my way so
you're not you're not in control
all you can control is the dialogue and
even then you'll have an actor who will
rewrite your line
but you can create a cinematic moment in
prose
where you create what appears to be like
a movie and
you can learn how to do it and once you
learn how to do it
and get over
all your impulses to not do it
because it's a technique you really it's
a tech just like in movie making you
have to know which lens to use
and you know when to go in for a
close-up and then it goes to the
editor's room and then they have to edit
it that that's technical that's very
technical and
the job of the editor who's editing it
is to make the scene on the screen not
look technical
he's got to make it work so you go
wow
major stross has been shot
pause
round up the usual suspects the end of
casablanca
so the editor cuts it in such a way that
you as a moviegoer feel the
psychological time so the image moment
technique i teach
is technical it's very technical and
when people learn to do it and they
finally get it
they're always amazed at how it works
and then
happens without fail
they'll say
i was reading a book the other day and
there were like five image moments on
every page
because good writers know how to do it
but it's not intuitive
it's not something you intuitively will
know how to do
oh i'm sorry i was just
trying to put this but it's so hard
one of the flaws in the design that i
never got that's really cool made
perfect that's really cool um
writing that'll live forever versus
writing that's a dead end you've made
that comparison with poetry i believe
why didn't you say that again sure
writing that'll live forever versus
writing that's a dead end
versus writing that's a dead end
is it is that what is your question
that's the question
let me try it again so
so in other words some writing lives
forever and some writing doesn't i think
you said that about poetry and you said
sometimes writers uh attempt to go for
writing that'll live forever but really
what they're doing is it's a dead end
how does a writer know that it doesn't
have to be poetry
or prose
screenwriting i i don't know if i have a
wise answer to that some some sometimes
you
you don't know
um you know some some of the things you
do you might think
aren't going to be especially
uh relevant or memorable and for some
reason
uh
it lives for a long time and other
things that you think are the best thing
you ever did
ends up being forgotten so it's kind of
hard to know it's kind of like
a crapshoot
you do the best work you can and you
hope for the best
you